3 mai 2005 stade de mogadiscio
ali mohamed gedi le nouveau chef du
gouvernement somalien fait un discours
dans la capitale
soudain à 10 mètres de lui une explosion
un kamikaze vient de se faire sauter
avec sa bombe
[Applaudissements]
il y a dix morts une centaine de blessés
le premier ministre lui est indemne mais
devant la menace il décide de s'exiler
dans le nord du pays
deux ans plus tard ce nuage de poussière
dans les rues dévastées de la capitale
c'est le convoi du premier ministre
rescapés
cette fois ci il revient en vainqueur
ces troupes appuyées par l'armée
éthiopienne viennent de chasser les
islamistes qui avaient pris le contrôle
de mogadiscio
mais la situation est loin d'être sûr
plusieurs centaines d'insurgés se
cachent encore dans les ruines
dans ce convoi un français il s'appelle
daniel bourzat il est conseiller spécial
du premier ministre et il est en
première ligne je suis un peu concernés
par la sécurité
parce que je suis souvent avec lui donc
je pense qu'il faut
je pense qu'il faut faire attention il
ya eu deux attentats contre le projet
mid dans le premier la première fois
nous nous sommes donnés à mogadiscio on
s'est pas passé s'est pas passée très
bon quoi
c'est donc sous haute protection que le
premier ministre revient d'exil il se
rend directement dans sa résidence
officielle à mogadiscio
après sa victoire militaire le nouvel
homme fort de la somalie a une ambition
reconstruire le pays
et pour ça il compte sur l'aide de
daniel bourzat
ici le français est un peu comme chez
lui tout l'entourage l'accueille comme
un membre de la famille
détails
ok que
via
il connaît mieux l'afrique que nous ce
type c'est un africain d'accord il est
blanc mais c'est un vrai africain
daniel est si familier des lieux qu'à
table il est assis juste à côté du
premier ministre et en plus il fait les
présentations
mais qui est au juste ce petit français
de 58 ans si proche d'un chef de
gouvernement africains
vétérinaire cela fait trente ans que
daniel bour sa vie en afrique et
parcourt le continent souvent aux
commandes de son propre avion
en 2000 il fait la connaissance du
docteur ali mohamed gedi lui aussi
vétérinaire et futur premier ministre
somalien
pourquoi avez vous demandé à daniel de
travailler pour vous
entre lui et moi c'est une longue
histoire
quand j'ai été nommé premier ministre
daniel a été parmi les premiers à me
féliciter à me soutenir
je les appelais auprès de moi et le
gouvernement français a accepté de le
détacher comme conseiller
en effet daniel bourzat a désormais un
statut diplomatique
et c'est le quai d'orsay qui le paie
autre atout du français aux yeux du
premier ministre somalien il
n'appartient à aucun clan je pense qu'il
a quelqu'un avec lui qui sait pouvoir
compter
et qui n'a pas de qui n'a aucun
aucune raison aucun intérêt particulier
à à lui cacher la vérité je suis un
petit peu le
celui qui lui aidé à
avoir une vie à garder une vision
la tête froide
et la tête froide il va falloir qu'ils
la garde car la mission de
reconstruction est un casse tête depuis
1991 la guerre civile a plongé le pays
dans l'anarchie et a fait deux cent
mille morts
avant mogadiscio c'était ça une perle
coloniale italienne dont les derniers
vestiges sont ces cartes postales
jaunies
voici ce qui reste de la cathédrale
ville cosmopolite
mogadiscio a toujours attiré les
étrangers
même au pire moment de la guerre mais
les dernières personnes à être rentré
dans le pays n'étaient pas des voyageurs
comme les autres
il y a quelques mois des volontaires
étrangers sont venus faire le jihad en
somalie
certains ont été capturés et daniel
bourzat a géré le problème avec leur
pays d'origine
un officier somaliens nous emmène voir
une vingtaine de combattants étrangers
des prisonniers retenus dans un endroit
secret près de l'aéroport pour la
première fois une caméra est autorisé à
les filmer
ils viennent du yémen du pakistan du
kenya et même d'europe tous affirment
n'avoir rien à se reprocher c'est le cas
de ce jeune homme de nationalité
suédoise
vous avez été capturés en tenue de
combat non non je portais juste un
pantalon tri
pendant que vous savez où mais ça tout
le temps c'est très à la mode
que venus vous faire en somalie
nous étions dans les émirats pour
visiter les pays musulmans c'était trop
cher quelqu'un m'a dit pourquoi on
n'irait pas en somalie
quand vous venez aux touristes ont ce
mal ils disent c'est que vous êtes un
terroriste
l'homme en chemise blanche affirme être
venu de syrie pour affaires
mon père exporte des voitures syrie en
irak
et il m'a dit vas voir en somalie s'il
n'y a pas des affaires à faire
ils se disent touristes ou hommes
d'affaires mais ils ont eu droit à la
visite des services antiterroristes
occidentaux
les américains sont venus en hélicoptère
avec des fusils c'était pour vous
capturez ils sont venus pour
m'interroger avec les kenyans ils m'ont
menacé
la cia
cia et je sais pas tout ce que je sais
c'est qu'ils étaient américains
l'officier ce malien s'impatiente il a
du mal à croire à leur histoire
arrêté personne n'y croit vos
explications sont loin de la vérité de
toute façon nous allons vérifier tout ce
que vous nous avez dit
touristes aux terroristes le nouveau
pouvoir somalien veut offrir à ses
hommes un procès équitable
et ce n'est pas la seule chose qui a
changé ici depuis la chute des
islamistes le gouvernement a de nouveau
autorisé le football la musique et le
cinéma interdit du temps des talibans ce
malien mais ces mesures ne suffiront pas
à ramener la paix daniel bourzat est le
premier ministre le savent du coup il
multiplie les rencontres avec la
population
ce matin conférence de réconciliation
entre les ennemis d'hier
dans ce genre de réunion le premier
ministre laisse rapidement le micro pour
que la population s'exprime dans la
salle les orateurs appel au pardon
collectif
arrêtons les massacres ne tuons plus les
gens sauvons les vivants nous avons
détruit notre pays et ses habitants tout
le monde doit faire table rase du passé
repartons de zéro et bâtissons une
somalie en paix
[Musique]
le but c'est de discuter pour trouver la
meilleure issue possible pour stabiliser
la ville mettre en place
l'administration locale
des réunions comme celle là daniel et le
premier ministre vont devoir en
organiser des centaines pour convaincre
la population
malgré la fragilité de son pouvoir ali
mohamed gedi dit vouloir instaurer une
démocratie à l'occidentale en somalie
je me suis porté volontaire je me suis
sacrifié pour tenter de ramener l'ordre
la stabilité la paix et un gouvernement
dans ce pays le reste le peuple somalien
s'en chargera et la religion la religion
appartient à notre culture
je veux être aux côtés de mon peuple je
veux conduire le pays jusqu'aux
élections
instaurer une constitution fédérale et
ramener la loi et l'ordre
la mission paraît presque impossible
mais ali mohamed gedi bénéficie du
soutien des occidentaux
après quelques heures à mogadiscio il
s'envole pour baïdoa dans le nord du
pays où un rendez vous capital l'attend
baïdoa
cela fait deux ans que le gouvernement
provisoire s'est replié dans ce gros
village de quelques milliers d'habitants
[Applaudissements]
comme dans le far west pour rentrer au
parlement ont laissé armes au vestiaire
cela vaut mieux tous les anciens ennemis
ont rendez vous aujourd'hui
arrivé en trombe du premier ministre lui
seul a le droit d'entrée accompagné de
son escorte
aujourd'hui la réunion et à haut risque
il s'agit d'élire le président de
l'assemblée tous les clans de la somalie
sont représentés aux côtés du premier
ministre daniel bahr a hélas comme
toujours
en bon émissaire il va saluer chaque
candidat
ministre
ump
l'élection va se jouer entre deux
favoris le candidat du premier ministre
et le candidat soutenu par ceux que l'on
appelait les warlord les seigneurs de
guerre ses hommes les voici ce sont eux
qui ont mis le pays à feu et à sang
pendant 15 ans aujourd'hui ils sont tous
devenus députés car le premier ministre
a fait le pari de la réconciliation
même avec ses pires ennemis
on peut en penser ce que l'on veut mais
il représentait une force qui ont
représenté une puissance qui
représentait un poids dans la société
dans la société dans la société malienne
donc
c'est assez logique qui se retrouvent au
parlement six pour daniel les choses
sont claires il n'en va pas de même pour
tout le monde
cet homme aux lunettes noires s'appelle
osman ali a tôt c'était l'un des pires
chef de guerre de mogadiscio
visiblement il ne digère pas que le
gouvernement soit soutenu par l'armée
éthiopienne
ils ont laissé notre ennemi pénétrer sur
notre territoire je dis non qu'ils
soient français ou éthiopiens je ne suis
pas d'accord
est ce que la guerre est finie
la guerre est finie où ça ici en somalie
vient juste de commencer
ces menaces à peine voilées et
reviennent vite aux oreilles de daniel
qui relaie immédiatement l'info un
membre de l'équipe gouvernementale
comme cause comme cause
non
this man mais ma grippe elle-même canada
vos photos
sur tard
ouais
mais au finish just athéna
oui il y a
justin theroux
blablabla will have to be extremely cafu
[Musique]
de sécurité routière
malgré cette tension la journée va bien
se terminer
finalement c'est le candidat du premier
ministre qui sort vainqueur des urnes
une nouvelle victoire sur la voie de la
réconciliation pour ali mohamed gedi et
daniel bourzat
mais malgré cette satisfaction
l'engagement du français a des limites
si un jour
la situation est trop tendue que je je
sente un risque évident de d'attentats
d'ilan lequel qu'elle contre le premier
est moi je me retirerai pas ce que parce
que
c'est quand même
je suis pas prêt à fait je suis pas prêt
je ne souhaite pas risquer mamie pour
les fautes
jusqu'à présent daniel vitte à nairobi
au kenya un jour il espère pouvoir
s'établir en toute sécurité à mogadiscio